ich habe euch auf instagram gefragt was
eure top favoriten auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt sind und da dieses jahr
die meisten weihnachtsmärkte auch wieder
ausfallen machen wir es uns einfach zu
hause selber daher gibt es heute topf
rezepte vom weihnachtsmarkt und wir
fanden direkt ankommt mit
[Musik]
wir starten mit kandierten äpfeln die
werden auch liebesäpfel genannt wobei
das hatte ich so ein bisschen komisch an
ist das so viel dass liebesäpfel genannt
ich weiß es gerade gar nicht das ist
egal
auf jeden fall brauchen wir dafür äpfel
ihr könnt euch jetzt entscheiden dem
tier schaschlikspieß oder im haus spiess
oder ich habe jetzt gerade kick off
spiele da und sticht auf einfach hier
vorne rein ja so perfekt und wichtig ist
dass man nie hat gleich tun kann das
bereite ich jetzt erstmal vor und dann
wird gleich zucker karamellisiert das
zeige ich euch nachher also eingefärbt
wird gleich mit rot aber theoretisch
gesehen könnte man auch andere farben
nehmen aber groß ist hat der klassiker
ich stehe jetzt hier direkt am herd in
dem sich jetzt entweder eine hoch
anfange so wie ich oder einen topf und
gibt da die folgenden zutaten rein
zuckerwasser und einem spritzer
zitronensaft ich lass das ganze dann
nämlich ordentlich karamellisieren es
dauert noch eine weile und färbt es
später mit meiner lebensmittelfarbe 1
[Musik]
das ganze hat jetzt zwölf minuten
gedauert ihr müsst aber auch nicht immer
umrühren also lasst es wirklich einfach
vor sich hin karamellisieren ihr merkt
dann dass die zuckermasse brown wird und
so ein bisschen dicker sie es halt sehr
1 reduziert ich glaube es ist wirklich
nur noch die hälfte von dem übrig was
wir vorher hier in der pfanne hatten und
jetzt wird eingefärbt ich nehme hier
eine sehr sehr stark pigmentierte
lebensmittelfarbe dass es meine eigenen
die verleger im shop und es ist
bordeauxrot sie mich mir nur so ein
bisschen weg und geht direkt rein und
dann werdet ihr sofort sehen war da hast
du mal rankommen sieht heftig aus das
färbt sich als sofort ein
so und jetzt können eigentlich den herd
ausschalten und direkt den liebesapfel
ich weiß sie ob so immer unverschämt ist
oder ob es wirklich so heißt aber ich
find's einfach mal so können wir jetzt
eigentlich direkt da rein ich habe
eigentlich ein anderer tipp für euch bin
ich unsicher wird weil das jetzt sehr
heiß ist dann gibt das gerne irgendwie
in ein anderes gefäß und tun dass rein
oder er bleibt halt direkt drin und geht
hier so am rand entlang und treten am 8
[Musik]
also in so einem gefäß das ist natürlich
ein bisschen einfach vor allem wenn ihr
später immer ein bisschen weniger hat
bei an jedem apfel bleibt ja auch
ordentlich was hängen und ihr könnt auch
quasi doppelt schichten also einmal
reingucken drehen und dann noch ein
zweites mal dann habt ihr eine extra
dicke schicht und ordentlich abtropfen
lassen und ich gebe das danach auf einen
backpapier und lasse es ein paar minuten
auskühlen und dann wird die hülle
richtig schön knackig und ich würde
sagen so machen jetzt weiter mit was
herzhaften nämlich dieser ganz typischen
leckeren champignons pfanne so ich habe
jetzt hier die baumscheiben bringen sie
können natürlich auch weißen emir können
groß in dem kleine die großen würde ich
allerdings vierteln und überlege die die
sind zwar schon relativ klein aber ich
glaube ich habe sie noch mal und
champignons werden nicht gewaschen weil
sie sich mit wasser versorgen sondern
sie werden nur geputzt das mache ich
jetzt eben und dann werde ich hier den
stängel so ein bisschen abschneiden weil
das doch ein bisschen hart ist hier
unten immer und dann geht es weiter
[Musik]
ich habe die zwiebeln auch schon mal
geschnitten für mich gern zwiebeln auch
immer dazu aber es könnt ihr entscheiden
und später kommt noch ein creme fraiche
tiff obendrauf und jetzt habe ich hier
in meiner fahne der wir hier schon mal
erwärmt da gebe ich jetzt butter rein
und ich mag die kombi aus butter und
olivenöl probiert das gerne mal aus und
jetzt gebe ich gleich zu aller erst
sieben reihen die werden dann so drei
minuten glasig gedünstet und danach
kommen erst die chance mit dazu
[Musik]
ich habe übrigens zum schluss nur noch
salz und pfeffer drangegeben die
champignons brauchen dann auch noch so
vier bis fünf minuten und dann ist es
fertig aber ich habe ja schon erzählt
ich mache noch einen quasi so ein
topping obendrauf dafür habe ich creme
fraiche ihr könnt ihr jetzt zum beispiel
auch schmandt nehmt das wird auch ganz
gut passen und was er mir nicht fehlen
darf ist knoblauch dann gebe ich da auch
noch mal ein bisschen salz dran und ich
weiß nicht wie ihr das seht aber ich
hoffe mal das gefühl dass auch dieses
dressing auf dem weihnachtsmarkt immer
relativ nicht flüssig aber es ist halt
sehr weich und deshalb kommt bei mir
noch einen schluck milch mit dazu und
dann verliere ich alles und gebt dann
noch italienische kräuter mit dazu
[Musik]
und als drittes machen wir die beliebten
gebrannten mandeln die fand ich ja
früher sind auch recht hochpreisig was
natürlich daher kommt dass mandeln recht
teuer sind ansonsten die anderen zutaten
zucker und wasser ist ja fast nix aber
ich weiß nur dass ich mir die damals
super selten gegönnt habe weil irgendwie
damals vier euro für 100 gramm oder
sowas war schon heftig so und jetzt gebe
ich hier ca in meine fahne am besten ist
da euer rand auch ein bisschen höher und
da kommt was mit dazu übrigens noch
nicht hoch gestellt die temperatur mein
geheimtipp ist jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen vanille extrakt mit dazu zu
geben um zimt darf er mir nicht fehlen
aber dass es auch optional und dann
ferro wir das am anfang einmal und
lassen es dann karamellisieren wichtig
ist das ist dann nicht mehr verrührt
[Musik]
die ganze masse karamellisiert dann in
wenigen minuten habt ihr auf jeden fall
immer ein auge drauf es reduziert sich
auch so ein bisschen ein und dann gibt
ja auch schon eure mandl mit dazu
wichtig ist dass sie danach ganz viel
geduld habt ihr könnt dann wenn die
mandeln drin sind gelegentlich umrühren
aber wirklich nur gelegentlich und dann
werdet ihr merken das mache ein paar
minuten die mandeln also die diese
karamell bisschen trocken wird und sich
an die mandeln quasi st die dem moment
alles noch mal gut umrühren und dann auf
einen backpapier legen da könnt ihr sie
auch noch mal vorab schon mal so ein
bisschen auseinander lägen damit sie
miteinander kleben aber das ist in der
regel gar kein problem und auskühlen
lassen und ich habe parallel habe ich
mir dann gedacht gibt es noch gebrannte
cashewkerne da habe ich dann auf dem
verzichtet also da ist einfach nur
vanille extrakt wasser und zucker und
könnte eigentlich auch mit anderen
müssen machen also ich habe gerne
genommen aber ihr könnt auch erdnüsse
nehmen oder schreibt mir nochmal in die
kommentare was für ideen habt
[Musik]
das waren meine drei top rezepte vom
weihnachtsmarkt wenn ihr noch mehr sehen
möchte schreibt doch jetzt in die
kommentare welche ihr gerne sehen möchte
und ansonsten werde ich euch noch eine
tolle playlist verlinken wo weitere
weihnachts rezepte drin sind und
ansonsten leute wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat hinterlasst einen daumen
nach oben und ein kostenloses abo damit
ihr solche rezepte auch nicht mehr
verpasst und dann sehen wir uns auch
über nächsten rezept
[Musik]